time for weather let's toss it over to
ted and the gang
derek you're hired
so much time for the game we are the
gang i'll tell you what
derek really he brought it in the dapper
department you pulled it off and you
know frankly ted i think we kind of
mailed it in today yeah
[Music]
well derek's got muscles yeah we're kind
of normal guys yeah that's that's not
going to happen
derek you're basically our studio cupid
we appreciate that that's nice i really
do thanks man appreciate it uh and i got
a flow fact for you guys so get this
okay yeah back in 2019 you guys remember
this on valentine's day 2019
we had over an inch of rain in one day
all right two inches of calico basin
that was a daily record of course but
there have only been 29 times we've had
over an inch of rain in one day that was
in 2019 wow it was raining like crazy i
remember you wrote that in all your
valentine's day yeah yeah it was a
washout
today no my hand hurt because that was a
lot of writing for all those valentine's
day cards for all you guys all right uh
yeah a certainly a different day indeed
compared to that in 2019 where we had
all that rainfall on valentine's day
over an inch of rain in one day that's
huge all right
currently outside new neighborhoods here
to show you somewhat 62 along with
centenni hills 66 for the lake 69
downtown same for green valley 64 roads
ranch 66 henderson southern highland 64
degrees so yes still mild out there now
even though we will be cooling things
off tomorrow well some of you may find a
little cool but at least not too chilly
66 in pram 64 boulder city 73 right now
for those of you joining us
down river and laughlin there's the low
that's going to be pivoting down towards
the region and as it does we've got a
couple things we've got the cold front
is going to pass through we call it
prefrontal winds from the southwest and
we'll also have the chances for showers
now here's your future cast nothing in
the morning and in the afternoon
certainly some snow in the mountains
again start to increase we need that but
we get to tomorrow evening and we'll get
some slight chances for stray showers
around the region it's 9 p.m tomorrow we
hope this changes even more tomorrow
we'll get more widespread stuff but
right now looks like just chances for
isolated stray showers and then we get
to wednesday morning it's out of here
all right winds will be increasing
though those gusts between 30 to even 45
inch spots we could see them up to 50
that's the reason for the wind advisory
temps will be dropping nearly 10 degrees
that puts us now near normal
after those 70s last week and there's
our shower chances in the evening snow
level be dropping to 4 500 feet so that
means we could get additional get this
two to four inches of fresh powder in
the mountains we need it yes 51
overnight mostly cloudy skies and we
will become breezy overnight nothing
tonight 64 for tomorrow windy and cooler
with a mix of sun and then clouds later
on as that front approaches and then
there's those chances slight chances for
showers mainly in the early evening
hours and maybe late afternoon eight day
forecast there you go yes we cool off to
the low 60s but look at your weekend
closer to 70 again for the weekend
slight chance of showers again next week
and another cool down
all starting monday next week that is
your most active forecast here on 8 news
now